auch heute wollen wir uns die
militärische situation in der ukraine
ansehen und es gibt tatsächlich
erschreckende neue bilder von russischen
panzerkolonnen die in die ukraine
hineinfahren die durch die ukraine
fahren wir gucken uns das einfach mal
hier an endlose panzer bewegung
sozusagen im osten der ukraine diese
aufnahmen sind aus der region aktiv dort
die wir sehen wurde hier von russischen
propagandisten gefilmt die ein
schützenpanzer nach dem anderen es
handelt sich hier um
wiederholungen diese fahrzeuge mit dem v
darauf wir gucken dass man hier sehen
wir dass mehrere faust darauf gezeichnet
um das ganz genau zu erkennen auch für
die eigenen verbände fährt hier in die
ost ukraine rein und wir wissen
mittlerweile um welche einheiten es sich
hier handelt nämlich es ist das
eingetreten vor dem alle gewarnt haben
der abzug von kiew der abzug in den
regionen cerny lief und zu mir im norden
des landes war überhaupt kein abzug
russlands das war keine deeskalation das
war keine irgendwie
verhandlungserfolg oder ähnliches
sondern es handelte sich um eine massive
umgruppierung neun tage lang sind diese
einheiten jetzt gefahren durch russland
aus dem norden der ukraine heraus das
zeigen dass man hier auf der karte aus
dem norden der ukraine heraus durch
belarus und dann hier außenrum russland
gefahren und fahren jetzt hier wieder
rein nach archiv und beginn noch einmal
zurück und dort haben wir weiter nach
vorne denn das hier haben wir hier
schützenpanzer gesehen verschiedener
gattungen was wir hier sehen sind
russische luftlande kräfte also die die
wurden von denen von den propagandisten
das gefühlt haben als die helden von
horst ohne bezeichnet also die helden
der ersten stunde die versucht haben
kiew zu erobern die am 24 februar
gelandet sind und dann versucht haben
vorzudringen und dann vor kirche aber
geschlagen wurden und zurück zurück
gehen mussten wir sehen am ende auch
dass es hier noch massive panzer
bewegung gibt das hier ist die die
vierte panzerdivision der russischen
armee auch die war in der region sowie
im norden des landes vorher aktiv
stationiert ist die bei moskau auch und
die ist jetzt wieder in der ost ukraine
auch die ist neu dar und bereitet hier
eine massive offensive vor und wir haben
aus verschiedenen quellen gehört nicht
nur in der ukraine sondern auch im
westen befürchtet wird eine oster
offensive befürchtet wird in der
kommenden woche wenn diese einheiten
alle sozusagen an ihrem platz sind und
bereit sind eine oster offensive von
putins während wir hier ostereier
sammeln möchte er massiv in der ost
ukraine vorstoßen und dort 30.000
afghanische soldaten einkesseln wir
zeigen das nochmal hier die karte haben
wir schon einige tage lang gezeigt
dieser plan war bisher nur ein szenario
was wir vorgestellt haben aber jetzt
bereitet sich die ganzen panzerverbände
die wir gerade gesehen haben wir zeigen
dass mal sind also in die region bei ifr
eingefahren und sind je nach easy um
unterwegs die sie um eine wichtige stadt
eine strategische stattfinden die von
russland hier besetzt wurde und von dort
aus wird versucht in den nächsten tagen
und wochen sozusagen hier runter zu
gehen und einen riesigen kessel zu
schließen um 30.000 ukrainische soldaten
wir hören dass putin zitat irgendeinen
sieg bis zum 9 mai braucht den neunten
mal den tag des sieges der in russland
in moskau mit einer riesigen parade
gefeiert wird das sieg über
nazi-deutschland den aber putin
instrumentalisiert um den sieg über die
ukraine oder ähnliches zu feiern und
nach der propaganda den sieg über die
faschisten in der ukraine das dazu wir
wollen uns angucken was denn die ukraine
macht wie sie sich darauf vorbereitet
wir wissen dass die ukraine unterwegs
ist sozusagen in den osten mit ihren
truppen auch die werden das verlagert
von kiew in den osten um dort die
gegenoffensive einzuleiten und ganz
interessante neue aufnahmen von
ukrainischen soldaten all diese
fahrzeuge die wir sehen sind russische
fahrzeuge fahrzeuge die die ukrainische
armee in den letzten wochen von russland
erbeutet hat die russen und bei ihrer
flucht vor kirche zurückgelassen haben
und auch wenn es sich vielleicht etwas
ziemlich an hört man muss sagen russland
ist der größte versorger demokratischen
armee mit schweren waffen all diese
waffen wir sehen hier ein btr eben
gerade und bmw hier ein t 72 auch der
absorbierte erste schießübungen weil die
ukrainer natürlich erstmal auf diesen
neuen waffen überhaupt sich ausbilden
müssen wir müssen erstmal gucken wie
geht das wie kann man damit schießen die
ukraine selbst hat solche panzer nicht
und auch hier sehen wir diese sehr
markante wird mahnung sozusagen die die
ukraine auf gemalt haben auf diesen
panzer um eben ja auch den eigenen
truppen zu zeigen das ist unser dass
keiner der gegner obwohl er so aussieht
wie ein gegnerischer panzer wir sehen
also hier diese schießübung und warten
wir noch mal einen schuss kurz ab die
ukraine wollen also wissen wie
funktioniert das was was kann man mit
diesem panzer machen
last but noch least wenn wir uns auch
ansehen es sind neue westliche waffen
angekommen in der ukraine auch das ein
gutes zeichen boris johnson war gestern
in kiew und parallel dazu oder einen tag
danach hat die ukrainische armee jetzt
ein video veröffentlicht wo sie eine
hochmoderne flugabwehrwaffen
großbritanniens testet oder benutzt und
zwar die sogenannte stars streak diese
rakete wird er eingesetzt gegen eine
russische drohne und wir hören einfach
mal rein in dem moment wo die rakete ihr
ziel trifft
große freunde heute also hier bei den
ukrainischen truppen die sagen super
dass wir das endlich können das war eine
kleine drohne die ist sehr schwer zu
treffen die aber eben das
artilleriefeuer auf die ukrainer
koordiniert diese truppe diese drohne
konnte abgeschossen werden insofern
haben sie noch den erhobenen
mittelfinger insofern hier große freude
bei den ukrainern dass zumindest diese
waffen aus dem westen endlich da sind
funktionieren und das ist die lage in
der ukraine heute